và hình sự của thế, RCC ngày hôm nay tả thơm mấy một đã bắt đến nghĩ
trả tự gió cho kêu tổng thống Philippine Roddy-Voru, tất cả các bạn định ông sẽ tiếp tục
ý ra mạnh tại la hay trong khi chờ sét sử.
Hồi đồng phút thậm chờ rằng, lý gió tôi cao sức yêu không đủ có sở để thay đổi
lạnh giám. Nói ra, nhóm bao chứ ớ cũng không chứ mình được việc lý giám giữ
đẻ gió á tính mạo của ông. Ông đủ tất cả thế, bị bắt tại mani là hồi tham bẩy
theo lận chuyện này à của RCC trong khốt khổ của điều tra trên dịch trên ám mà
hả thông tần AFP giả lời các quan trức RCC trong viên mặc dù bị giám giữ
khi anh ông đủ tế tệ tả mấy tuổi, bắt được chăm sóc y tế và có sức khoải
on định RCC giữ kiến tổ trước khi anh điều trần tiếp theo vào năm 2020.